find the probability of rolling even
numbers three times using a six-sided
die numbered from 1 to 6 so let's just
figure out the probability of rolling at
each of the times so the probability of
rolling even number so even roll on
six-sided six-sided die so let's think
about that probability well how many
total outcomes are there how many
possible rolls could we get well you get
one two three four five six and how many
of them satisfy these conditions that
it's an even number well it could be a
two it could be a four or it could be a
six so the probability is the events
that match what you need your condition
for right here so three of the possible
events are an even role and it's a out
of a total of six possible events out of
a total of six possible events so there
is a three over six the same thing as
one half probability of rolling even on
each roll now they're going to roll they
want to roll even three times and these
are all going to be independent events
every time you roll it's not going to
affect what happens in the next roll
despite what some gamblers might think
it has no impact on what happens on the
next roll so the probability of rolling
even three times so the probability of
rolling even three times is equal to the
probability of an even roll even roll
one time or even roll on six-sided die
this thing over here is equal to that
thing times times that thing again all
right that's our first roll let me copy
let me paste it times that thing and
then times and then that times that
thing again right that's our first roll
which is that that's our second roll
that's our third roll there independent
events so this is going to be equal to
one-half that's the same 1/2 right there
times 1/2 times 1/2
which is equal to 1 over 8 there's a 1
in 8 there 1 there's a 1 in 8
possibility that you roll even numbers
on all three rolls on this roll this
role and that role